The more recent story is Jessica Cruz who? This funniest one.
This is the funniest one. I mean, if we're going to measure them on funny. Yeah.
Rachel dozer was the funniest. Yeah. But now Jessica Kruger,
if they went out on the road, Jessica Kruger would headline and Rachel dogs,
I would feature Jessica crew weld. Well, if they went on the road, yeah.
Jessica crew headline, Rachel dolls, all featured,
but the Oprah would be Jessica Cruz.
Alter-ego Jessica [inaudible] Jessica LA boom,
by boom, by Lana. So Jessica Kruger,
who's a white woman born and raised in Kansas city,
Jewish white woman from the suburbs of Kansas city. Yeah.
She took on the alter ego of Jessica [inaudible] Lana and
posed as a African Afro Caribbean woman and actually
used it to get jobs and was a tenured professor at George Washington university
for like 15 years, teaching studies,
African-American studies and complaining about how white people are ruining
this country. When she in fact was a white woman ruining this country.
I mean, it's really great. Can we play a little clip,
please play that clip talking at the city council because on the zoom meeting.
Yeah. I mean, now is this so, so, uh, psychopathy to use she's associate path.
It's how can you just lock plate side? It's being it's psychopath.
It's being a sociopath. It's it's uh, you know,
not being able to be okay with the conditions of your life.
It's wanting to be a victim. It's entitlement. It's insecurity. Here we go.
Here we go. You think this is more Risa Rodriguez. Y'all be honest.
His comedy videos.
Yeah. I'm just up on Barletta. I'm here in the Barrio is Thailand. Uh,
you probably know this neighborhood cause those are kinda Melissa.
I just wanted to make sure the viewer, the listener understands right now,
our fans are saying that this is a white woman from Kansas city who has not yet
come out publicly and said, she is in fact, the Whiteman from Kansas city.
She's still playing this charade and she's still playing this race card,
which I genuinely believe at this point because of the things that are happening
in our country, she needs to be brought up on federal charges.
There needs to be a charge. You cannot do this. Now I disagree.
She got away with this for like three, four bucks, 13 years.
She made a whole career out of it.
She's a professor at George Washington university,
very prestigious university with a very prestigious job. She's been able to,
if there should be a rule, if you get away with it for 10 years,
you've passed the test. You, you, you you've achieved something. Fair enough.
And you become black. Fair enough. Get your car where they say, you know what?
Good on you. You fooled us for 10 years. You win. Fair enough yet.
It's almost like, yeah.
If you're like cheating on your wife for like 10 years and you don't get caught,
you have another family after the 10th year. It's like,
you have to just now everybody's just gotta be okay with it.
There's nothing anybody can do. I want,
there's gotta be a statute of limitations on how long you can be canceled.
If you can. If you got away with something for 10, 20 years,
you can't cancel somebody. You have to tip your hat to them. Tip your hand.
If you say good job,
Jessica [inaudible], we should have to her Jessica boom ball era
, which is the funniest name. You think she was just sitting there going like in her brain.
Do you think she talks like that to herself in her brain or her brain sounds
more and more like, yeah. Cause she's a Jewish girl.
She's like a Jewish girl from long Island from Kansas city.
So do her thoughts sound like this or in her own head?
Does she change it and say, listen,
these white here are not yielding their time to me.
Cause they gentrified my neighborhood and I'm just [inaudible] and I won't have
any time for these white devils coming in my neighborhood.
Cause I'm an unrepentant childhood hood dot fat.
That's how she does a hundred percent, hundred percent. Your thoughts?
Sound like this. Hi. Hi Christie. What are we going to do today?
We're going to wake up this morning.
We're going to get ourselves to black and white. Cause we've been good,
but we're going to be a little naughty because we can reward ourselves for
working out with Anthony. God did Anthony look at this morning?
Yeah.
Is that how you're that's it. But then they come out like I'm Kristy. I'm a guy,
but in your brain. Yeah. What is your,
what is the voice in your head sound like when I wake up truly, when I wake up,
when am I eyes open? And when I'm in bed,
I'm waking up my body and brain wakes up. I think I'm a woman.
It's not till my feet hit the floor.
And do I hear the creaks of the floor and realize how much weight uncaring do I
remember? I'm a man. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Because when the feet hit the floor,
they're shaped like a high heel. Yeah.
So you're still a woman until you stand up and you carry all that weight. Yeah.
And then I just see my penis and then one day I just, you have body dysmorphia.
When you look in the, uh, what is that? Gender dysphoria, gender? This morphine.
It must be weird to have the soul of a woman and then see a very ma you have a
man. We had, I know it's tough. Your head looks like it's a helmet.
It was almost like if I, my face and I put on a helmet, right? Like it's like,
you have a natural helmet. You've got a big protruding male brow.
You look like a real guy's guy. And then you come out and you're just your soul.
It's like, yeah,
you're a man. You w you walk, you present as a man,
but your soul is 100% Whitney Houston. He used to baby. I come, I love it.
I'm alive. Yeah. No, I it's just what it is. Yeah. I, I am.
I'm not a hundred percent, but I would say 70% sure that if I make it to 50,
the last 50, I will, I will try to go as a woman. Now, if it's to feel,
if you bend out Jessica [inaudible] right.
And you found out she was Jessica Krug,
would you get less attracted to her? Less attractive, more attracted? Yeah. Her,
Jessica LA Bloomberg. And I went to no strings. I mean,
she's going to get the construction book. She's going to get one off the face.
Now, if you want to know what the construction put me into, just like a picture,
somebody who's just been painting all day, what their boot looks like. Yeah.
It's a lot of white stuff all over it. All right. So let's, let's let's see,
are those boomers, she kind of looked like a piece as well. My nails,
she looks like a Pittsburgh dozer also was kind of like a piece,
but here she is here. She just looks like a fat. You don't like lesbian. Yeah.
So here's, here's Jessica Love Bumble. It be the reader.
Who used to be the speaker, your city council.
So my neighborhood to developers and gentrifiers.
So I got a couple of things to say.
And when y'all come on and tell me my time stops, outta here.
It's been seven hours.
Not only did I have to listen to these cops and not just the cops,
but to be honest, the council members you pose on,
like you opposing them for your soundbites, for your social media,
for your via election campaigns. out of here.
You've been supporting the cops in the pandemic when the MTA was strapped and
you supported putting more cops on the MTA, outta here.
We know where you're coming from. And we know what these little,
I also want to call out all these four hours.
You know, a lot of it is you can get away with this amount of in that world,
because let's just be honest. Most of that world is. I mean,
you go to study like here's where you're taking a class on jet,
whatever it's all or math and science and history. What happened?
It's what it is. This whole like activist version of academics. It's all.
You could come in and say anything.
It's like this whole field or culture of,
of, of liberal arts through the lens of like
victimization comes with a certain amount of. Because humans are,
no matter what color they are. And they're also great,
no matter what color they are.
So this is actually more racist than anyone who's walking down the
street, who's going. You know what? We got to get rid of this shirt, neck, neck,
or whatever the they're saying, because you know what I mean?
At least that person, you know who they are and you know, okay,
they're small minded. Whereas this is an actual vulture.
She's like a leech. She's saying I'm against gentrification.
She is the gentrifier Boca.
But why to Jessica crew Krug Krugie lumberman air.
Why did she come out and say she got outed by a, I was going to say,
so it's not like it was on her own accord.
Like she had this existential crisis inside of her.
Something was about to go down. And she said, let me,
let me M and M she came clean and she M and M that Reggie eight mile debt by
coming out to try to get ahead of it and just admit everything.
Cause it was about to come out.
She had been found out she was a Jewish woman from the suburbs of Kansas city.
Went to private school. She's been estranged from her family.
She even skipped her own mother's funeral because she felt like that would
expose her because her mother's white brothers, white she's white.
So it was a Latin student, an Afro Caribbean,
Latin student who started to question her when they started to actually talk
about this prominent, um, Hispanic writer who, uh,
he, uh, this Cuban, uh, Afro Cuban writer,
or she didn't know who they knew, who, uh,
a member of history in these fields or whatever.
And it turned out that they found out, in retrospect, he was lying.
He wasn't Afro-Cuban.
So he was lied to pass in this world of like, Hey, what's up? You know,
we're trying to the white devils. Wow. So a student uncover this dude.
It was about to uncover mint. And she came clean in media. What actually,
can we read the stuff like, well, yeah, that's what happened.
So the student was about to catch her. So she came out, she said,
I'm not a culture vulture. I'm a culture leach.
I'm from a great part of my adult life. I've been living a lie.
She's been lying. And the best thing is, is like, she goes hard.
She attacks white people. Constantly. One of her neighbors was a white woman.
Always said like, this is the problem with y'all. She's a smart kid.
She's got a PhD from the university of Wisconsin. Got a PhD in this,
to be honest, what the is sociology? Gender studies. It's.
You got a PhD. I'm not calling anyone. Who's got a PhD in sociology.
A doctor. We need to stop that. Let's just call it something else.
What can we call it? You got a PhD in. So it's a PHB. Yeah.
You're a something. Something posts. What is it? Post humeral. Doctorate.
Post general. Yeah. I mean, you're a doctorate, but let's,
you're closer to a doctorate.
Then these people who have a doctorate in medical field,
cause at least you can put your hands on my balls and tell me if I got cancer
and I need to ask you again, can we do it after the episode?
Are you having some problems? No, but you're a guy. Here's the thing.
You're a guy. When you touch another man,
you know how to separate do it medically. Yeah.
Cause you've touched my back a few times and I didn't feel weird.
I didn't feel like gay about it.
You know how to just put that aside and handle someone physically medically his
cosmic don't mistake. After I did that to you,
I went home and I hit my pocket. hard.
Yeah, because you're a doctor. You're a doctor. You're a doctor, Dr.
Rabbit doctorates. So, so this lady, Jessica Cruz, Jessica boom,
by the Adda much like Clarence King for whatever Clarence King decided to do it
for love. She decided to do it to be a victim and to get involved,
to get ahead in life. I think she should beat. There should be.
There is a crime here though. I understand the 10 year rule,
which I'm willing to give you a pass on this,
but there should be some crime here that needs to be kind of brought up. But no,
it's the same thing as like, uh, the long Island medium or John Edward,
what was his name? John. Like, you want to believe the. I mean,
if you want to believe it's a good point. If you're there. I mean, it's like,
well, you're going to put up the long Island medium on charges.
Cause she's pretending to speak to Larry. I mean, if, if yeah, if you,
my mom's been talking with dog sidekick, try to get in touch with Larry.
She's saying he's not there yet. I'm going to pass out.
Cause I got COVID Tucson, extra lightheaded,
but we really hope you enjoyed that episode. Whatever it was about.
This is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate, review us, subscribe,
turn on your notifications,
get jiggy with it and go to patron.com/bay Ridge boys.
Things get really wild.